this is the very first third-party
magsafe puck on the market that actually
charges at 15 watts just like apple's
original max save charger and today not
only we're going to compare every single
feature and design element between these
but also the true charging speed to see
if it is actually faster because of the
newer better design and i believe that
there are multiple reasons why you
should buy this one instead but there's
also a few that you have to know about
before buying it because there are some
limitations now we have tested many
third-party mac safe charging pucks like
this one which looks almost identical to
apples take a look at that
but they charge much slower instead of
maxing out at 15 watts it actually will
only charge at up to 7.5 if you're lucky
so even though it looks very similar and
it does have a little bit of a lower
price tag you do not get that fast
charging speed but unfortunately so many
of these third-party manufacturers will
advertise 15 watts on their listing
pages and that fools a lot of people and
then they buy it and wonder why is this
charging so dang slow so don't be fooled
by that now let's put that to the side
and let's take a look at belkin's brand
new charger now there's something very
interesting about this before i open it
taking a look all around we have the
different specs and features but right
here it says it's made for the iphone 12
line we have the 12 pro max all the way
to 12 mini it does not list the iphone
13 and i actually found this box right
here this is belkin's boost up charge
pro that i did a video on about a month
ago this actually lists the iphone 13
meaning that belkin was working on this
product for a long time and they
actually wanted it to come out before
the iphone 13 was released so this has
been a long time coming i don't know why
they did not release it but anyways
let's go ahead and open it up we have a
nice packaging here
bam
you see the puck right there looks
similar to apples
except for we don't have that aluminum
on the side so you don't get the premium
material there
but let's go ahead and pop all this out
and one feature that really kind of
stood out to me was the cable take a
look at this guys we have this nice
raided cable that looks really good now
i have to say this is a really nice
braided cable apple's magsafe puck does
not have that even though they are using
braided cables for some of their
products now and in general everything
including even this little connector
piece seems even higher quality than
apples now you guys also notice that we
have this little cable tie with a little
snap built in and the silicone kind of
feels like apple silicon so i'm guessing
maybe apple has certain standards that
belkin has to
apply with or use in order to be
featured at their store and have access
to the 15 watt charging which nobody
else has access to but that is really
nice now the reason why they have this
little um cable tie is because this
cable is much longer than apples take a
look at that you guys can't even see
it's completely in the in the camera
shots but this is i believe a six and a
half foot cable and if we grab apple's
magsafe puck look this thing is much
much shorter actually let's go ahead and
put these side by side here
my goodness as you guys could see
belkins is twice as long
as apple so if you're somebody out there
that wanted to have just a mac safe puck
on let's say at your nightstand and you
want to be able to charge but then also
if you're in bed you want to be able to
snap it onto your phone and just chill
there and be able to charge while using
your phone well the belkin charger is
going to be much better for that because
of just how long this cable is and they
actually advertise that on the box being
able to scroll or game or stream
whatever you want and still have access
uh to this wireless charger not have to
be you know next to the outlet there now
with that i'm also curious about the
magnet strength is the belkin's charger
more superior so let's go ahead and
attach the max safe one
pretty good fit
has some magnet strength i don't think
it'll pop off on accident side twist
strength is decent as well i've had
really no complaints but it's not too
hard to remove it let's grab belkins
this does seem actually the magnets a
little bit stronger takes more effort
to take the charger off and we don't get
the little magnetic shifting when we're
going side to side that's very
interesting too now it could also be
just because it's larger but yeah
definitely no weaker and i would say it
is a little bit stronger as far as
magnets and that makes sense because it
is thicker now the other feature that
you guys probably see right now is this
built-in kickstand so that is really
cool especially because this thing is a
little bit thicker as you guys could
tell
maybe even three times thicker it does
taper down a little bit but because of
that size i'm really curious about the
charging speed if it can cool itself
easier and pull any heat away from the
coil and the battery that would mean
that it could charge quicker
but that kickstand is really nice if
you're using this uh you're you know at
your bedside or wherever really and you
want to charge but you also want to prop
up your phone and be able to watch
something well you could do that and of
course with apple's magsafe charger you
can't now before i do that charging
speed comparison let's talk about a few
downsides the first one is that it does
not come with a charging adapter in the
box thanks to apple leading the way and
who knows they might even have
requirements for belkin not being able
to include one of these 20 watt power
adapters so if you do not have a usbc or
you have 18 water you will want to buy
one that's at least 20 watts to get the
proper charging speeds now the second
one is that this thing costs more money
even though it doesn't come with that
power adapter it is 60 dollars compared
to 40. we thought apples was already
pricey and it is
but they're charging even more than
apple does now i kind of understand it
because one you get a much larger cable
that is braided two it also has the
built-in kickstand and in general the
quality of this thing is awesome i have
to say the kickstand has no play
whatsoever a lot of the third-party
options kind of suck they're flimsy they
could easily break so you are getting a
quality product with extra features for
that price now the third downside is if
you buy belkin's option you have to be
aware of this you will not be able to
use one of the many third-party
accessories that have been created for
apple's puck so for example we have this
adjustable stand that is very
inexpensive kind of lifts up your phone
off of the table and you can kind of
adjust it whichever way you would like
of course there's many car mounting
options there's so many different
accessories for these pucks that you can
buy now that won't matter if you're just
planning to use it at your desk but if
you want to have the ability to change
up what you do with it in the future you
are not going to have that with belkin's
charger and now with all of that out of
the way let me go ahead and go and do
some testing and we'll see just how fast
belkin's option is alright guys we are
done and as you know these charging
tests take forever so hit that thumbs up
button if you guys appreciate it i use
the same phone as before same power
adapter 20 watt from apple and we have
some interesting results so after the
first 10 minutes the belkan is actually
slightly slower at 9
compared to 10 but jumping another 10
minutes to 20 it is actually beating it
out now at 22
and then the trend kind of goes on after
a half hour the bell can reach 33 charge
compared to 30 now of course it's not a
huge difference
but it is charging the phone faster
which is interesting and then let's jump
all the way up to 50 minutes and here
the lead gets even bigger we have 51
compared to 46 so that is 5
higher charge than apple's puck now i'm
guessing that's just because of the
larger size and less heat because the
iphone does limit the charging speed
based on thermals
now going up longer let's say let's go
to an hour and 15
here we actually have an even bigger
difference now six percent so as you can
see it kind of fluctuates a little bit
there and then jumping to an hour and 45
minutes we have 91 charge compared to
84. now if you guys don't know when
you're wirelessly charging once you hit
90 percent the charging slows down
dramatically so here after 91 percent
the belkan slows down apple starts to
catch up so at the two hour mark we have
a difference of six percent here 90 with
apples 96 with the belkins and at 2
hours and 15 minutes the belkin actually
finishes up it finishes that last amount
fairly quickly so it takes 2 hours and
15 minutes for the belkin magsay 15 watt
charger to fully charge this iphone
whereas the iphone with the apple
charger it actually takes two hours and
45 minutes to fully charge so yes the
belkin charger is faster as well likely
just due to thermals and not heating up
your phone as much being able to suck
some of that
heat out of your phone and it charges 30
minutes faster than apple's puck that
apple makes themselves so if you're
somebody that wants to use wireless
charging but you also want to charge
faster then the belkin is better at that
compared to apples and then of course it
has the extra features with the longer
cable and that kickstand as well so
there you guys go let me know down below
where any of you guys expecting a
third-party option to actually charge
faster than apples using the same exact
20 watt puck or 20 watt adapter with
this puck i want to hear your guys's
opinions and which one would you buy
would you just stick with apple's one
for 40 bucks or would you be willing to
spend the extra 20
for belkin's option to have those extra
features overall i have to say that i'm
fairly impressed i did not think it's
going to be this high quality um this is
even better quality at least the field
than apples even though it doesn't have
aluminum the plastic is excellent the
pad here is nice and soft the kickstand
is great having this long cable is nice
and with that cable tie so if you don't
need the extra length you don't have to
use it and then of course for traveling
it's nice to be able to pack it up nice
and small
overall i'm very impressed and i would
highly recommend this option now if
you're somebody wants to save some money
there are still third party options that
look very similar into apple's you'll
get the fastest charging speed so if you
don't care about that we'll go ahead and
link all of this stuff down below in the
description of this video go ahead and
click that circle above to subscribe to
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been max
and i will see you in the next video
[Music]